most people make their money from not
writing boxed applications but actually
writing custom software and making kind
of improvements to software and fixing
stuff with other people and actually
free software it's a wonderful place to
do that kind of work I've been doing
free software for a long time previously
I worked way way back now ten years ago
in NHS IT it's the National Health
Service IT projects based in Leeds in
the UK and my job there was really to
maintain some free software we were
using to power our website so we had
people plone and we're using apache and
linux and canoe and debbie and all these
other things to kind of make this thing
happen so my job was primarily to make
sure that keep they kept working to add
features to it to add new functionality
and to kind of maintain it and so I was
paid to that job and I left there I went
to the University of Manchester and had
a job that also paid me to make and
maintain free software and there's kind
of an overriding pattern here where I
did that for a lot of my jobs the Free
Software Foundation my job was more
focused on campaigning
I was the master head behind some
campaigns like effective by design
Windows 7 sins play oak for a couple of
years and so I would write articles and
I would do a lot of editorial type work
on those things but at the same time
maintaining my own free software
projects in my spare time and now I'm a
Creative Commons and Creative Commons
sir price price pace pays me to look out
for free software projects and to
maintain and write free software and so
if you would like to work in this kind
of field I would suggest you become
reasonably good at programming you know
your licenses know your background and
kind of have a strong desire to make
free software a reality and people need
free software developers and WordPress
is a great example of a very very calm
piece of free software that's not going
away anytime soon people will always
need people to write plug-ins help
people be supportive
right themes right add-ons for WordPress
and if you're really good at free
software development then you can even
you know work on WordPress itself you
know WordPress is community project too
so we will need the people who work on
WordPress
our volunteers primarily in their spare
time but some of them also work for the
company behind WordPress and so I think
the very best WordPress developers in
the world get the opportunity to go and
work full-time as their paid job on
WordPress so if you have to start
somewhere you don't just get a job in
free software from nowhere but you can
you already have a job writing
programming doing programming stuff you
probably already use some free software
tools see if you can convince your boss
to allow you to release your changes out
to the world and if you can then find
the right community and give them the
changes back and you could very soon
find yourself doing that for a living in
terms of organizing team
the way it really works is that if you
are a developer a new enjoy piece of
software you can be part of its upkeep
so generally speaking most software
that's free software is developed in
public using sites like SourceForge
historically or nowadays it feels like
--get aureus and github you can go along
get a copy of the code find bugs fix
bugs add new features and kind of push
that code that you've made back to the
main development team and general what
happens is there's kind of a process
whereby you you send in a few or a few
bug fixes a few like suggestions and
then eventually after a while they get
kind of like this guy's okay we'll let
him into the team and then you become
part of that development scene if they
use git for example go and check our
copy of the get code and make your
changes locally but also as you make
your changes check those changes into
gear so that you have your own version
of that code locally you can kind of
back and forth through it and you can
kind of see what you did along the way
and make when you make commits to that
git project make good comments so you
kind of remember what you did and don't
just leave a one-line sarcastic response
which is what I often do try and leave
good comments and that way you'll kind
of be able to go back in time and see
what you did and then when ultimately
when you eventually get those changes
that opted by the big community project
they will be able to see the same thing
you can see they'll be to see what you
did and so it's not so important to
structure your code super well because
as long as you kind of make it work and
you make good comments then that can be
cleaned up afterwards look at companies
like MySQL and Red Hat and they've made
lots and lots of money from doing free
software stuff so you were definitely
canonical does have teams developing
certain pieces of free software I think
the news people are cool in Red Hat is
that Red Hat develops software that's
generally widely used by all the free
software users like genome desktop and
other things whereas I think what
canonical does is a different model
where they actually develop kind of
their own free software they release it
as free software but it's mostly used
for the abun to community and the
ability users it's not so widely used
outside of the bun to mean that's that's
not an unreasonable thing that's a you
know perfectly valid way to create
software you know and of course there's
nothing stopping the teams at Red Hat
and other companies and other
organizations from taking the canonical
code and reusing it for other things you
know so if you are going to take code
from other projects and you can of
course do that that you make sure that
the code you take is and releases that
works for the license or taking things
into so for example if you're taking
code from WordPress you can't really
take that code and put it into a project
that's not under the GPL you would have
a hard time wrangling that you have an
even harder time getting your changes
taken in by another project because that
file would then be under a Paley's
partially under the GPL you should never
let that kind of thing to sway to you
from taking stuff because it's free
software it's there to be taken but at
the same time you should just know the
obligations that you don't have as a
developer to kind of make your changes
available to people so that you know
when you when you take your widget from
dling this GPL you put it on the put it
on the web you don't have to make sure
people can get the source code to your
to your changes to you can't just that's
the share alike part of things exactly
yeah
have companies that is whatever reason
don't want to use free software will
then take advantage of them and sell
them a copy for two thousand dollars or
ten thousand dollars wherever you can
get but the same product true free
software at the same time for those of
us who are in the community that want to
take it and improve it and share it